you
[Applause]
I am an immigrant from Uganda living in
the United States while waiting for my
asylum application to go through
migrants do not enjoy much freedom of
movement in our world today this
certainly applies to those who are
desperate enough to navigate choppy and
stormy seas in boats these are the risks
my cousins from West Africa and North
Africa faced while trying to cross over
to Europe indeed it is a rare but
fortunate opportunity for a migrant
address a gathering like this but this
also signifies what often is missing in
the global debate over refugees migrants
and immigrants voices of the
disenfranchised citizens of many host
countries even though that previously
will come to newcomers
an easy about the rising numbers of
individuals coming into their countries
the immediate criticism is that the
newcomers upend the stability of social
welfare and employment in their
countries and certain and skeptical
citizens look towards politicians who
are competing against each other to see
who can claim the prize of the loudest
voice of populism and nationalism it is
a contest of who is the toughest on
migrants the most willing to impose
travel bans and the most eager to
propose projects in building walls all
these restrictions simply address
symptoms of the problem not the causes
why are they coming migrants can share
perspectives if only politicians could
be willing to listen in Dubai our own
code in justices and inequalities
inflicted regularly on the migrant labor
force as a result pressures from the
government of the respective countries
led to me being forced out of my career
as a generalist in the Middle East I was
deported to Uganda where economic
deprivation puts everyone at the risk of
starvation and I fled Uganda to come to
the United States in the hope of
sustaining a voice for my brothers and
sisters who experienced a more serious
plight as migrants
my father told me he was not happy about
me writing a book that risk deportation
and unemployment he had been diabetic
for manias when I still worked in Dubai
and my Sutter was always sufficient to
pay for his treatments after I was
expelled I could not afford to sustain
his treatment and even in the last days
of his life I could not afford to take
him to a hospital as I carried his body
in my hands to lay it in the ground in
June last year I realized I had paid a
profound price for amplifying my voice
the act of speaking up against injustice
say that a multi-layered is never easy
because the problems require more than
just a rhetoric so long as gold mines
oil fields and large farms in Africa
continue to be owned by foreign
investors and those vital resources are
shipped to the west the stream of
African migrants will flow continuously
there are no restrictions that could
ever be so rigorous to stop the wave of
migration that has determined our human
history before Border Patrol's can be
tightened and the new visa restrictions
imposed countries that have long
received migrants should engage in a
more open discussion that is the only
practical start for reconciling finally
a legacy of exploitation slavery
colonialism and imperialism so that
together we can move forward in creating
a more just global economy in the 21st
century one that benefits all
[Music]